here's aaron nola his 20th start six and
six the era of 4.64
and uh we all talked about aaron's uh
struggles
this year from time to time let's hope
he can dial it up like he did on opening
day six and two thirds two runs six
strikeouts against the braves
ground ball to first one out that's two
up and two down for nola and it brings
up freddie freeman
nope fastball right out over the plate
yeah 4-3 on the put out one two three go
the braves nice start for aaron nola
tooky's second start of the 20-21 season
i don't know that you can pitch any
better than he did against another
star-studded lineup that featured by the
san diego padres back here in atlanta
absolutely you see that four career
starts against the nles this is very
interesting through 66 fastballs in his
last start that's the highest fastball
usage he's had in a single start in his
mlb career i thought he challenged
people and i'd love to see more of that
today how about that start three pitches
down and away from segura and there's
out number one two down base is empty no
score at the bottom of the first inning
and a curve ball strikes out bryce
harper how about that start for tooky
toussaint three up three down austin
riley will lead off curveball way down
strikeout number one for aaron abraham
almante is the batter the one-two
swing of the miss he got him fastball he
swings to it and another strikeout for
aaron nolda
ball's popped up behind the mounds
hoskins comes flying in ahead of the
smaller players to make the catch race
hoskins is the battery
and tooky with that curveball it is
unbelievably good to start third
strikeout two outs
one for eight in the series with an rbi
and this one on the ground to second
toussaint six up six men down no score
in game four it'll be kevin smith
leading off for atlanta as we go to the
third kevin smith tooky toussaint and
then the top of the order oh gosh i
almost hit him
i don't think he picked that one up i
don't think he did that's the third
strikeout for nola
swinging to miss
four strikeouts don't let the healthy
hack fool you doorbell's ringing
here's jack peterson he's back into the
wind the 3-2 on the way swinging a miss
he struck him out basketball got him he
stays with the heater he strikes out the
side as the braves go down in order one
two three in it will be albie's freeman
and riley do up part of the order for
the braves
fly ball right field not deep
as bryce harper comes in makes the catch
austin riley over one with a strikeout
and riley shoots one into the left field
corner that's gonna get down and to the
warning track mccutcheon backhands but
not before austin riley stands at second
with the braves first hit his 17th
double
and the first man to get to second is
austin reilly for atlanta today there's
dansby swanson with two outs and a man
at second swing and a miss
first seed fastball strikeout number six
for nola no runs
a hit a man left in scoring position
gene over what he struck out his first
time up
that one out toward left going back on
it as almante it's gone
into the first row
home run number six the billies are on
the board
it's one to nothing
that home run was built for this
ballpark one on one out mccutcheon
popped out to dansby back in the second
inning
and that was tipped he tried to check
his swing and the ball hit the bat
there's a big break fourth strikeout for
tuki toussaint on an excuse me check
swing from andrew mccutchen philly's
trying to add on to this one nothing
lead here in the bottom of the fourth
inning oh dubo herrera over one with a
ground out to second base
broken bat up the middle and that should
be a can of corn for dansby it is and
toussaint gives up the lead off homer
and nothing else it's one nothing
phillies
and there's the second out brings up
kevin smith that's out to left and
mccutcheon makes the grab as he falls to
the ground
nine pitch hitting for
aaron nola through five he's allowed one
hit we go to the bottom of the fifth
one-nothing phillies alec baum will lead
it off working quickly another fast ball
you know what
got him on a called third strike i think
boehm goes up there looking for breaking
balls all the time sagura struck out on
three pitches to start the game in the
bottom of the first and then homered
curve ball how about that sequence a
repeat performance of what tucson did to
him in the first inning six strikeouts
for tukey now it's time for the braves
bats to go to work so two down and
here's the dangerous freddie freeman
he's over for two today kind of that
concept we talked about before that's a
mile high fly ball right center field
he's in a slump oh duble tracks it makes
the catch
nine pitch hitting back to back nine
pitch hittings for aranola bryce harper
singled his last time up dumped one into
left field
which harper didn't get that sunk out of
sight that's seven strikeouts for two
side he had five last time out against
the padres he's gotten harper twice
catching his flight out and struck out
let's not forget about him let's not
forget about this great sixth inning for
tooky toussaint he has struck out eight
it's a one nothing thriller in philly
and austin reilly with a double to lead
things off in the seventh there's dansby
swanson ground ball back toward the
middle sigour diving stop throws to
first in time
oh
doctor he saved a run got it out one
away here in the seventh so here's how
mate the phillies are playing the
infield in
lift it in the air shallow left field
not deep mccutchen's there riley's going
back he's not gonna tag two outs
so that'll leave it up to guillermo
heredia
ball to third right at foam
and the inning is over how about the
play by gene segura saved a run pretty
much saved the inning took you back out
there for his seventh inning of work
would face hoskins herrera and bone
and he swung and missed at a breaking
ball in the left-hand batter's box
strike three nine strikeouts matching
the career high good start to the inning
alec balm singled in the third struck
out looking in the fifth the 2-2 pitch
struck him out it's a new career high
for tooky toussaint what a way to finish
a brilliant outing in philadelphia 10
strikeouts one run aloud kevin smith
who's over for two swag you miss nola
picks up his first strikeout since the
fourth inning now pablo sandoval all
will bat for the braves
ground ball over to the right side
segora has it throws from a knee in time
and there are two outs yeah quite a
defensive day and offensive day and so
here's peterson
swag and a miss he got him with the
curve
eight strikeouts for aaron nola he
finished his eight innings this
afternoon for the first time since april
18. and he did it with a little bit of a
flare ronald torreira starts it off
great
field going back is out monte gone now
a career high for home runs
he's just given the fills a little
insurance here at the bottom of the
eighth inning it's a two-nothing game
it'll be aussie albies freddie freeman
austin riley as aaron nola is in search
of his second complete game shutout not
in a complete game shutout this year
now we got him nine strikeouts for nola
out to left field mccutcheon on the run
makes the catch two outs
it's up to austin reilly to keep the
game alive
swing and a high fly ball wallop to
right it's a home run
austin reilly with three extra base hits
that spoils the shutout the braves down
to their last strike are still alive
it's two to one
so aaron was done after eight and two
thirds
116 pitches getting a standing o from
the 20 000 on hand here at citizens bank
park little tip of the cap one more out
to go to the pitch
flag and the miss he got him he threw a
change up again and the fills have
earned a split of this four game series
thanks to a 2-1 victory this afternoon
and the pitching of aaron nola